our Siri is a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us is far greater
than what divides us today we're gonna
take a look at two families brought
together by chance the story shows how
strangers can share a person's memory
David beg no visited a hospital in
Louisiana and found a connection between
two patients who never had a chance to
meet hi David good morning hi Gail Happy
New Year we received a special tip that
led us to Lafayette in the heart of
Cajun country this is a story about the
circle of life and how joy and grief can
bring us together almost a year ago
this little baby entered the world in
Lafayette Louisiana
his parents connie dis pani and benjamin
hall named him Kingston but they didn't
have a middle name until right after he
was born the name they decided on came
from a letter that they got in the
hospital a surveillance camera at
Lafayette General Medical Center had
captured a stranger asking for
directions so she could deliver that
letter but who was she - my dad's angel
even though I will never know your name
you are the first child born here after
my dad's passing when one life is taken
and others giving please keep my dad in
your prayers
his name is James thank you that was the
stranger Jamie Fontenot shortly after
her father 86 year old James League
remet a veteran died in the hospital in
Lafayette
Jamie heard sweet music it's a lullaby
that plays throughout the hospital
families of newborns come here and they
press that button in the labor and
delivery Ward playing the lullaby
letting everybody know a newborn just
arrived on January 12th 2018 Kingston
Hall was born shortly after mr. grimace
died the timing seemed more than
coincidental to Jamie somebody said well
then that's dad's angel so with no
escort you just took your letter and I
just took my letter and I went to the OB
unit I said my dad passed away about
10:40 so give this to the first baby
that was born after that time on duty
that day was dr. Jennifer pugilist and
Sydney beg no a registered nurse they
received Jamie's letter and dr. Pugh
jelly's brought it to Connie and she
started reading it silently and she just
had tears streaming down down her face
and it was really beautiful it came in
and then the dad says oh we found our
middle name and I'm like great what is
it and he says well it's James of course
and I'm like oh my nurse followed me to
that side and she was like well do you
mind if we get your information and give
it to miss Jamie she didn't mind at all
we asked her if she remembered who that
nurse was I know her name was I think he
was Cindy Sydney Sydney yeah I think it
was sitting there missing you so that's
my mom really that's awesome thank you
mom
yes it was my mom who helped to deliver
Kingston and then told me a story of how
a stranger wrote a letter to Connie who
then decided that the best middle name
for Kingston would be James in honor of
mr. Griffith I think I'd ever see you
the best part for Jamie was holding
little Kingston James what are we to
take away from a story like this family
is everything and if you don't have
faith you don't have anything you just
never know when a blessing is gonna come
and fall in your lap so you all will
stay in touch we all want to clap so
we're just gonna play some good updates
first of all we have pictures let me
show you how cute this little nugget is
right so this is him today that was the
christening and look Jamie was there at
the baptism and baby Kingston James that
little nugget is grown up he's healthy
they say he had little tubes put in but
not baby precious David are you and your
mom just sitting around talking and she
just mentions his story and passing you
go hey mom what happened story one night
now remember getting off the phone thing
you know that's a good story I think she
called me the next day and she says oh
they're actually gonna meet I said oh
that's really good and I called her back
and I said okay wait a minute tell me
things but you had asked the hospital if
we have permission to tell mom is
assignment editor that's a reminder of
kind of what we've been talking about
today social bonds yes
gratitude family is everything and love
would shape is everything think about
the way you give by writing a letter
through your grief yes and the joy she
brought to that family beautiful sounds
of a lullaby - yeah David thank you but